1 hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live keynote webinar the laboratory
clinical partnership opportunities and
challenges my name is donna del monte
and i'll be moderating the session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots that the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by roche
diagnostics as a global leader in
healthcare roche diagnostics offers a
broad portfolio of tools that help
healthcare providers in the early
detection prevention diagnosis and
treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics roche diagnostics is driven
by a vision of working with laboratories
like yours to improve the medical value
you offer in biology women's health
microbiology genomics and oncology the
company continues to meet unmet needs
through its investment in research
innovation in scientific excellence with
the goal of supporting your important
role in improving patients lives to
learn more visit us Diagnostics Roche
com so let's get started this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits you
can pose questions to the speaker
throughout the presentation while their
impression your mind to do so simply
type them into the Q&A box which will
open when you click the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower
left I now present today's speaker
William Valenti MD is senior vice
president of strategic advancement staff
physician and chief of innovation at
Trillium Health Rochester New York he
oversees Trillium helps research
programs and new programs service
development and implementation he is the
co-founder of Community Health Network a
Trillium Health legacy organization and
has been doing HIV medicine and primary
care since the early 1980s his clinical
interest focuses on streamlining systems
of care to ensure accessible and
affordable health care for all patients
dr. Belinda believes that our
understanding of population health
should translate to the care of
individual patients his mantra is that
you need to practice in the setting that
you supervise he did his postgraduate
training in internal medicine primary
care and infectious diseases at the
University of Rochester Medical Center
Strong Memorial Hospital he is clinical
associate professor of medicine at the
University of Rochester School of
Medicine and Dentistry he is chair of
the infectious diseases Committee of the
Medical Society of the state of New York
and most recently served on the new york
state health department's task force to
end the HIV epidemic by 2020 as co-chair
of the medical care committee dr. blenny
will now begin his presentation hey
thanks Donna thanks everybody and
welcome let's just jump into these
slides and four objectives here's what
we're going to do and i'm going to leave
time for questions at the end so please
ask questions and make comments because
this is I think the lab clinician
collaboration is important so we'll talk
about some opportunities there and talk
about the lab role in improving patient
outcomes a little bit about some
reimbursement challenges that we faced
and have resolved in fact so let's go
some quick opportunities these are some
things that come to mind things that
have really been important
in our lab setting clinical setting to
make patient care better one is
colocation the lab patient service
center is right in our clinic this
improves patient adherence make sure the
patients actually get their blood drawn
before after the visit and it's just
extraordinarily convenient in the era of
electronic health records online
ordering and we've been able to link the
labs database to our electronic health
record so that we can both order from
the record and also lab results come
back into the record for our review
customer service is important I'll talk
some about this give you some examples
but I'm in regular contact with our lab
reps and we also have a staff member who
is a liaison between our clinic and the
lab so that we can get answers to
questions quickly and I think quick
responses is really important here
things like alerts during business hours
versus off hours lab calls us with
alerts or out of range values and we get
results cancelled test reports those
kinds of things so that there's a pretty
regular stream of communication that I
find very very helpful in terms of
taking care of patients which is what I
do well there are some reimbursement
challenges that we faced recently maybe
an opportunity to for many of you who
are watching this and we were recently
detik designated a federally qualified
health center FQHC and one of the things
that is required in that rubric is a
sliding fee discount for patients is
based on household size and income and
the requirement for us is that all of
the partners and referral sources even
that we use need a similar sliding fee
scale that's based on income and
household size reduces the the cost of
care for people and
eliminate some of the out-of-pocket
expenses so it makes care more
affordable now without the sliding fee
scale by our lab we would have needed to
partner with another lab so you can
imagine that we worked very hard at
preserving the relationship and going
through all of the channels to make sure
that this passed muster and it did so
the lab sliding fee scale is now into
effect and one of the things that it
does is it makes the testing component
of the care that we give more affordable
for patients avoid sending patients to
collections patients keep their
appointments get their labs done and I
think in many ways helps improve patient
outcomes so a little bit about how I
view my world and my fellow providers in
general providers when interfacing with
the lab are more concerned about the
availability of tests are you doing the
tests that I need for my patient we do I
have to send it off some the patient off
someplace else so availability timely
reporting absolutely critical and I'll
give you an example that in a minute and
then because we link test results to
care I mean I make clinical decisions
all the time based on laboratory results
in general we're less concerned about
the test platform the machine that's
used the mechanics behind it less
concerned about that and less concerned
about the the methodology so give us
results but I think it's important to
sort of give those results and have
those activities centered around the way
people think so let's talk a little bit
about some advances in technology that
help improve patient care here's another
discussion of how i think i think in
clinical terms and when thinking about
sexually transmitted infections i think
very simply and i think logically in
terms of body site and disease state
give me a throw culture
or GC you're in urethra for chlamydia
and gonorrhea rectal for CT ng and a
cervical for CT ng just very very simple
now here are some of the challenges that
we faced because this is not how I think
this is a dizzying array of something
that popped up in a patient summaries I
was reviewing a record to get this talk
ready and it kind of looked at it and
thought you know this really doesn't
make sense there's no logic logic to the
way it's ordered we have trouble with
the numbering system i'd rather have
things come out in alphabetical order
because that's how it another way oh I
think but gonorrhea is spelled the
English Way it spelled two different
ways there are a lot of there's a lot of
discussion about the test methodology
and platform and so if i want that when
i went back and looked at this and then
tried to compare it to the results of
the chart i found this now here's
another dizzying array of results that
come back to a template in the chart you
can see that it really it's a fact by
logic so we have worked on and worked
very diligently in terms of organizing
lab results when they come back into the
electronic record and organizing them in
a logical fashion so that they make
sense clinically and that i can make
clinical decisions based on what I've
you and sometimes I view this in a hurry
and rely on other people to feed me
information and when I go back and look
at something like this don't know good
news is we've been able to work it out
and we have ordered the templates in
logical terms and in clinical and a
clinical format another opportunity is
to think about responding to trends in
healthcare I'm going to sort of present
this in an infectious diseases HIV
framework because that's how
spend most of my time these days but HIV
is a very dynamic disciplinary Jamie
medicine and there's a lot happening
like a fast-moving train on many days
but some trends in HIV care include now
recommendations for treating all
hiv-positive people with antiretrovirals
regardless of cd4 count or viral load
that cd4 count versus viral load is
another hot topic of discussion i'll go
into this in some detail but in general
where we are relying less on cd4 counts
for our patient monitoring and much more
on viral load as a to follow treatment
on antiretrovirals and also talk a
little bit more about this in terms of
some of the newer strategies to identify
infection earlier one of those is in the
HIV prevention world as a biomedical
strategy and I'll talk about this in
more detail later pre-exposure HIV
prophylaxis prep which involves one pill
a day a biomedical approach one pill a
day to block to prevent HIV infection
the other big trend for us has been with
hepatitis C and with the advent of new
drugs shorter courses of treatment
hepatitis C virus is a curable infection
today and it has been a dramatic game
changer in terms of the way we manage
hepatitis C the outcomes with hcv as the
these new drugs have come through the
pipeline another emerging infectious
disease is the Zika virus just another
opportunity to begin to think about
Diagnostics there's no commercial
commercially available diagnostic
for Zika right now it's available in
through our state lab but as emerging
infectious diseases like Zika gained a
foothold there are more opportunities to
incorporate they those kinds of
diagnostic tests into our workflow so
think about some trends in terms of
incentives align we all want to do a
good job for taking care of patients but
sometimes the way we work the ways we
work aren't quite aligned and I am a
firm believer in our lab people agree
with us that the lab work flow really
needs to be in sync with our clinical
needs an example we have begun to pay
close attention to early HIV infection
the HIV seroconversion syndrome called
acute HIV infection or aah i includes
viral load testing as a part of the
diagnostic I realize that HIV RNA is not
FDA approved as a diagnostic we'll talk
more about this a little bit later but
the problem was that our tuesday-night
clinic which is an STD clinic and also
now a prepper free exposure prevention
clinic requires that we have access to a
viral load testing results quickly and
the lab was able to do another run on
Wednesday morning so that we have
results the next day so they're now
doing a viral load testing for us on
Monday Wednesday and Friday but in other
words adjusted their workflow and
activities to accommodate our clinical
need and that has been a lifesaver
certainly for our clinical program but
it's also helped a lot of patients just
a quick point that I thought about in
terms of do you know how your customers
a clinical setting is or
organised we talked a lot about this
with our lab because we have providers
we have two clinical pharmacists to work
right in our clinic liaison between
clinic and pharmacy and lab and our
nursing staff are very active in terms
of laboratory ordering through standing
orders and also organizing results and
getting results to us quickly so it's a
very dynamic multidisciplinary activity
that we have going on there the
electronic record I love technology I
really do especially when it works
sometimes it doesn't always work and I
thought that maybe we could eliminate
more paper than we did with the
electronic record so I'm this is a plea
to avoid paper at all costs and really
make sure that they lab interface works
and that the results come back
electronically and avoid I'll save a
tree but also avoid the redundancy that
comes along with sending results both by
the electronic interface and also on
paper so some relevant areas of
Investigation in HIV medicine today
post-treatment controllers we're still
trying to understand why some people
really never progress to aids from HIV
infection have high cd4 counts even
though these people need to be treated
there's a unique opportunity there to
under have a better understanding of the
immune system that might be applicable
to cure strategy or even vaccine the HIV
eradication cure strategy is really a
very active area of investigation this
speaks to our understanding better
understanding of the HIV reservoir and
trying to actually do a sterilizing cure
active area of investigation
and along with that is the use of a
single copy HIV RNA essay which has
great appeal to me this is a very
seductive kind of from idea for those of
us who have been doing HIV medicine for
a long time I realized that it's not
available as a clinical diagnostic it's
still very much a research tool but a
very active area investigation again as
we try to characterize the HIV reservoir
in an effort to see if we can actually
do this sterilizing cure so lots of
activity in that area another area that
I'm going to talk more about going to
come back and forth in this discussion
is modern era HIV prevention the
biomedical prevention pre-exposure HIV
prophylaxis or prep very very active in
terms of HIV prevention so let's rethink
HIV a little bit here and talk about
some of the modern era trends in HIV
care on my side that also have some in
fact a lot of relevance to what goes on
in the laboratory and how we use the
laboratory and how we collaborate
treatment Cascades you may not have seen
this but I have a couple of slides this
is the United States treatment cascade
this is our starting point here in terms
of numbers of people who with HIV who
are diagnosed or aware of their
diagnosis numbers in the last year so
I've been a little bit higher but you
can see that as you go through this
cascade from numbers of people diagnosed
to those who are linked to care retained
and care on antiretrovirals and a viral
suppression that it decreases to
twenty-five percent of United States
patients who have HIV actually have a
suppressed viral load implications for
the lab well in to diagnose site on the
far left a lot of HIV tests that still
need to be done if there are million or
so people with HIV who do not know their
HIV status point-of-service testing
rapid testing a huge huge opportunity
and we do this in our lab also does a
4th gen test that i'll show you the
schema in a minute the opportunities for
viral load testing as we try to increase
that number on the far right from it's
now about thirty percent of all people
united states with HIV have a an
undetectable viral load but as we talk
about ending the HIV epidemic there's
considerable work to be done here and
certainly opportunities for testing
getting results back to providers
quickly interfacing them with the
electronic record next slide oh I have
control here I'll do it I'll take care
of that well here's another cascade the
one I showed you previously was for the
United States this is New York State's
cascade of HIV care from 2013 it's
similar to the previous slide for the
u.s. gives us some benchmarks though for
those of us in New York so that we can
see where we are how well we're doing
you can see that about a hundred and
thirty thousand people with HIV
infection as you go down through this
cascade you can see that about 70,000 of
those people are viral load suppressed
which is about fifty five percent of the
total population it's better then the US
as a whole but there's still a lot of
work to be done it's only fifty-five
percent what about the other forty five
percent is the question the end the HIV
epidemic strategy in
in in New York State and action in the
United States really requires that we
get on this and do any better job of
retaining people in care and viral load
suppression to the lowest level possible
so that's what's happening with some of
the those strategies it leads into this
discussion of ending HIV as we know it
and I'll get to that in a minute so HIV
modern arrow but the goal of treatment
today is an undetectable viral load and
it's not just for the clinicians and the
patients that we have social workers and
care managers and the mantra for them is
the same the goal with the reason you're
doing housing or helping this patient
with housing insurance or employment
issues is to get them to an undetectable
viral load it's a multi-disciplinary
effort and is becoming a global effort
biomedical HIV prevention as I said prep
is really on the radar screen I'll give
you some details on that in a minute
here's the modern era agenda though for
HIV it's ending the epidemic and here
are just three examples of plans that
have been developed in recent years that
speak to that on the Left National AIDS
strategy for the US which is updated to
2026 got the White House on it that's
the u.s. plane they're similar i'll give
you the detail in just a second and the
epidemic end aids the yellow report is
the 2015 blueprint from new york state
is a statewide effort to reduce a number
of new infections in new york state to
under 750 per year by the year 2020
that's a remark that will be a
remarkable remarkable public health
achievement there are currently 3,500
new HIV infections in New York State so
it's a statewide 200 million dollar
effort to to do this
bottom is the fast track plan of the
World Health Organization they say by
2030 we can end the HIV epidemic
globally really really ambitious
ambitious efforts and the laboratory is
pivotal in these efforts here's the new
york state plan and the HIV epidemic by
2020 18 2020s what we call it and there
are three key points identify and test
people who do not know their HIV status
opportunity all over the place hospitals
admissions hospital emergency
departments urgent care settings in fact
a couple of our urgent care settings in
our area referred patients to us and
they do because they do rapid testing on
site there all right if the individual
is HIV positive link them to care retain
them in care remember those Cascades
what the Cascades are about and achieve
an undetectable viral load undetectable
viral load for all and then the big big
new kid on the block is prep for
high-risk negative people I'll give you
some detail on that in a minute I keep
saying I'm going to give you detail and
they promise i will just a little bit
about modern era monitoring now in this
within this framework of ending in the
epidemic these are guidelines from the
New York State Health Department CDC
says the same thing this is from january
2014 what that first bullet says is that
routine quarterly CD for monitoring
really isn't recommended anymore their
quarterly monitoring doesn't really tell
us what we need to is because the
antiretrovirals modern era
antiretrovirals just works so well that
if people take them it's really viral
load second bullet that is the most
meaningful measure of effective
antiretroviral therapy and that cd4
comes sort of tell you where you've been
but viral load HIV RNA tells you where
you are it's a very different
a different approach in this modern era
and as we move toward 2020 going to be a
lot of HIV RNA testing and some CD for
monitoring but not the way we used to
really your treatment on the radar
screen finally the pendulum has gone
back and forth over the past 30 years on
this and we no longer wait until the cd4
count drops below a certain level in
other words offer antiretroviral
everybody who's ready in treatment
readiness is important here and we work
on that with patients but the idea is to
offer antiretrovirals to all
hiv-positive people regardless of cd4
count or viral load implications for the
lab as I said fewer cd4 counts for more
HIV RNAs the other thing that we're
doing as I mentioned earlier was
hepatitis C testing and also the the
Roche assay is now the HIV RNA test is
approved as a diagnostic so the
situation the story is evolving very
quickly but about forty percent of our
HIV patients are hepatitis C co-infected
so we're doing a lot of co-infection
treatment and as i said earlier epoch I
to see if done correctly with modern
arrow drugs and monitoring is curable so
this new agenda ending HIV is it
realistic you know I think it is I think
that I think we really need to have them
work a coordinated effort and rally
around this elimination of HIV infection
or certainly reducing infections below a
certain threshold if we don't get to 750
in New York State by 2020 I bet we'll
come awfully close so there's this
biomechanical or functional cure that's
the treatment cure with in HIV people
who are taking antiretrovirals I'll talk
a little bit more about stopping
transmission but if you're under the
viral load is under a certain level
generally under 400 and some of the
studies that have been done but in other
words undetectable viral load prevents
transmission transmission of HIV
events forward transmission and call
that treatment as prevention and
certainly as a serious impact important
impact on morbidity and mortality some
active areas of research in the HIV
prevention area as i said earlier
include pre-exposure prophylaxis vaccine
is still on the radar screen it's going
to take a little while though for
vaccine to be developed so in the
meantime prep or pre exposure
prophylaxis which is one pill a day to
prevent HIV is as good as a vaccine and
it's pretty good here it is so this is
the Gilead drug truvada it's two
antiretrovirals and one pill once a day
and as I said it's the next best thing
to a vaccine if you take a look at the
eligibility for prep I know this is a
kind of a busy slide the important thing
about this slide though is that it digs
into testing in clinical terms and if
you look at option 3 on the right you'll
see that this CDC algorithm that talks
about prep eligibility talks about the
testing schema that starts with rapid
testing with then differentiation test
if necessary and then speaks to HIV RNA
testing so it's on the cdc and new york
state health department's radar screen
so this and I think you have access to
the slide set so this is worth looking
at in terms of the eligibility prep i'll
give you the simpler version right here
on this slide first of all the data the
evidence for prep once daily at one pill
a day there are many many clinical
trials that have been done the best one
was the grants 2010 summary of this I
prex trial which was a global
trial several thousand patients
placebo-controlled so it's a good trial
showed a ninety percent reduction in HIV
infection in those people who took prep
who took it they measured blood levels
of truvada so they're able to tell who
really took and who didn't so take the
drug it works and as a significant
impact on reducing new HIV infection in
high-risk people most of these people
were gay men or men have sex with men in
this trial another trial observational
from Kaiser Permanente in the San
Francisco Bay Area 2015 no new
infections in this observational trial
several thousand people who took prep it
works it does who are the candidates for
prep well men who have sex with men men
we have unprotected anal sex that is
anal sex without condoms transgender
women significant risk situation may
have 50 50 times 50 times the risk of
acquiring HIV over time compared with
men who have sex with men on transgender
men big status couples 12 men have sex
with men to male partners one is
positive one is negative the negative
partner definitely a candidate for
prepper we talked about this with the
partners negative partners of our
patients on all the time heterosexual
especially those who are trying to
conceive we have made several babies in
our HIV population where the generally a
man with HIV on treatment undetectable
viral load and his female partner HIV
negative goes on prep and we've seen
some good results with that injection
dart users also although injection drug
users because of the availability of
exchange and clean needles are a little
bit lower on there is a risk group for
HIV infection these days nonetheless
people who are actively using drugs are
good candidates for prepon it's worth
having that discussion with them I
mentioned treatment for prevention a
little bit earlier there's a great
global trial this HPT no.5 to study that
looked at early versus late initiation
of antiretrovirals the sort of put there
the discussion the argument to rest in
terms of when to start antiretrovirals
as i said earlier the pendulum has gone
back and forth over the years in terms
of when treatment should be started but
the people who were started on treatment
as soon as they were identified or as
soon as they came into the trial at
ninety six percent less lower risk of
HIV infection than those people whose
treatment was deferred until their cd4
counts fell below 300 in other words
there's really no reason to wait I
realize there are insurance issues and
other treatment readiness issues for
people we work through that and really
get people ready for treatment as soon
as possible so the study really does
support the case for earlier treatment
and it is obviously has benefits to the
individual patient but also a public
health benefit in terms of reducing the
risk of forward HIV transmission that's
what end the epidemic these end the
epidemic strategies are are all about so
early treatment equals HIV prevention
great great study and welcome in this
modern era of HIV well the other thing
to sign the radar screen that has direct
relevance to us clinically as well as to
the lab
is acute HIV infection remember that
there were about 55,000 new cases of HIV
in the United States every year and many
of them have what we call a cute HIV
infection that's why cleverly titled the
slide hiding in plain sight a lot of
these people end up in emergency rooms
are urgent care settings with this
flu-like illness that's called a
flu-like illness and they're signed out
and they're HIV infection goes
unrecognized so here's a case study
somebody we saw at the end of last year
26 year old man who has sex with men
came in for prep and they sounded like a
pretty good candidate for prep as we
talked to him he gave a three-day
history of fever with a rash on his back
and on his chest did a fourth-generation
point-of-service test the rapid HIV test
net was positive lad did the multi spot
differentiation test quickly and we
started him on three drugs that day
because there's some evidence to say
that if you can identify people in the
secure seroconversion phase of HIV that
you can actually change the course of
illness over time it may not even need
therapy for the long haul it's still an
area of investigation but the point is
we in collaboration with a laboratory
were able to get results that resulted
in a really rapid clinical decision next
day is viral load came back nest a next
day his viral load came back greater
than 10 million copies so it was acute
HIV infection it was as though we both
the book on it but we were able to get
work with the lab get quick results and
make clinical decisions quickly that
will likely change the course of illness
for this patient
improved diagnostics are really critical
here and it just been huge huge game
changers in all of this so going from
right to left first to the numbers are
the generation of the test first through
fourth I like the 4th gen test with p24
antigen we were used from p24 antigen 25
years ago as a surrogate for viral load
before viral load testing was available
I know it may not have been as relevant
as we thought back then but 25 30 years
later comes back incorporated into this
point of service fourth generation test
so at least we've been validated that
way but anyway you can see that the see
that dashed line in terms of days after
HIV infection when the test becomes
positive nucleic acid testing or HIV RNA
is the current gold standard we use both
but in order to really close that window
completely CDC New York State Health
Department say consider HIV RNA if
there's any doubt for example discrepant
results in the screening test versus the
differentiation test or indeterminate
results on one or the other the other
thing is the confirmatory test is the
differentiation test or and or viral
load I'll show you the schema in just a
minute but we really have eliminated
Western blot and the recommendation is
that Western blot testing is is no
longer relevant in this modern era it
just takes too long to become positive
in isn't doesn't meet the needs of
modern era HIV care just very very
quickly how did we discover HIV
infection as I said it's been hiding in
plain sight and that's because of the
the history of HIV starting on the right
in the 1980s we first became aware of
disease aids the sickest people it
wasn't until the 1990s that we got a
better handle on the clinical latency
a piece of this the asymptomatic HIV
infection which is a obviously a huge
piece of this but as Diagnostics have
gotten better as we started to talk
about ending the epidemic as the drugs
have gotten better better tolerated and
able to be used as a lifetime regimen
we've finally been able to settle in on
an identifying and better characterize
acute HIV infection so it is definitely
on the radar screen and we need to
accommodate that in this clinical
laboratory interface because it's
becoming a big piece of what we do
here's a CDC testing algorithm again not
going to walk through this except to say
look at the far right it begins to talk
about indeterminate results that lead
people to an HIV RNA sa big piece of
modern era HIV Diagnostics one last
slide here so this is just to wrap up
the discussion on acute HIV infection
remember we used to call some of these
indeterminant their discrepant results
of false positive HIV well not anymore
because we really need to rule out acute
HIV infection and this language comes
from new york state health department's
recommendations clinical guidelines
activity they talk about obtaining a
plasma HIV RNA test do the RNAs a to
make sure that we are really talking
about ro is it a false positive test or
does it represent does this represent
acute HIV infection now they refer to
the Western black there but as I said
the Western blot tests and said all but
disappeared so I'm going to close
just a little quick summary here this
collaboration that we've been talking
about needs to reflect contemporary HIV
care or clinical needs in general on the
HIV side and question is there are
incentives aligned to end the epidemic
and really optimize clinical outcomes
access to new technologies is important
and getting that rapid fourth generation
HIV test on site has been very important
to what we do and if we can't do the
rapid we can always send it to the lab
because of the 4th gen is rel remember i
talked about timely results but the real
bottom line here the unifier is regular
communication between clinicians and the
laboratory and as i said we have a
number of people in our clinic who
interface with the lab on a regular
basis and in fact i talked to our lab
director just yesterday about a couple
things and we troubleshoot troubleshot a
couple things and got it taken care of
so the communication piece absolutely
critical I will stop there take a breath
and see if there are any questions well
thank you dr. Valente for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
he'll answer as many questions as time
permits dr. Valente the first question
we have is what strategies have you seen
to be effective at retaining patience
and care well retaining patients in care
great question big part of and the
epidemic and see a lot of us pay
attention to well what goes on at the
end of the stethoscope write a
prescription and you're out the door the
real heavy lifting beyond what I do
comes from this multidisciplinary team
that I work with social workers nurses
clinical pharmacy
is lamb but overcoming barriers to care
or the social determinants of health
care housing housing is health care if
you don't place to live unlikely you're
going to have clean water and unlikely
that you miss your medicine in fact I
saw a case just the other day health
insurance issues overcoming barriers to
health insurance getting people signed
up on insurance and also getting them
plugged into insurance that works for
them high deductible insurance plans for
some people are like having no insurance
at all so we do a lot of insurance and
navigation food we have a food bank in
our probe with our program so that we
also do some meals during the week of
congregate meal in other words
overcoming some of those social
determinants things that keep people
from getting to their appointments
transportation we got out a lot of bus
passes Medicaid in New York also has a
taxi service that it's covered under
under Medicaid you know those kinds of
things things that are more than just
writing a prescription and listening to
the patient's lungs but addressing some
of those other social issues that need
to be addressed remember that a lot of
HIV people are from minority populations
there marginalize a lot of other issues
that keep people from from accessing
care and and staying in care staying
connected to care what else what tips do
you have on how clinician groups or labs
can contribute what see you again what
tips do you have on how clinician groups
or labs can contribute can contribute
all I think I I'm not sure let me see if
I understand the question the
lab clinician contribution to what
ending the epidemic talking to each
other and working together you know what
else though the thing that does come to
mind is HIV testing screening people for
HIV whether it's point of service or
sending it to the laboratory the other
thing that's difficult for people to do
sometimes as a sexual history sometimes
it doesn't take much more than just
asking people if they're sexually active
and if they have sex with men women or
both I don't find answering the question
but anyway I think these things are
important so thanks for bringing up this
contribution piece and also the other
thing that is important here is the
linkage to care that if you don't do for
example one physician group doesn't
really do HIV care they could be doing
HIV testing referring people to the lab
for HIV testing and identifying or being
familiar with a provider in the area who
does the other thing is think HIV
prevention think prep and at least know
that there's one pill a day that people
can take high risk people can take to
prevent HIV infection okay well thank
you dr. Bell any for your presentation
and like to ask if you have any final
comments well yeah I do the part about
collaboration in terms of staying in
touch we used to this reminds me we used
to do a quarterly lab conference with
our lab people and our providers and I
think we should revise that so we're
going to do that but the other thing is
my experience recently in going back and
forth with the lab director on a couple
of service issues but
an impression on me was first of all
number one she responded quickly and
number two by the end of the day she
resolve the problem now that's good
service I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions we'd also like to
thank our sponsor Roche Diagnostics for
underwriting today's webcast this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits this
webcast can be viewed on demand through
October 6 2016 lab roots will alert you
by email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye